America's Got Talent first live show
what you didn't see on TV and you my
friends are my golden buzzer last night
marked the first night of live
competition for a GT the first with Tyra
Banks as hosts Tara hit the stage as if
there was a fashion runway and she was
just as fly backstage when I talked to
her about her live a GP debut but there
was one mistake she was afraid of making
her first live show as host of a GP how
you feeling I am feeling really good
no no mess-ups during rehearsals I twice
said America's Next Got Talent I was
like mmm so I did not say that live
thank God because you're juggling so
many shows through many shows with
America and it oh listen I mean this
power big still get nervous because you
didn't show it I don't get nervous when
I'm myself okay so I am myself but if
this was me acting on a stage and it was
Broadway I'd be a hot mess
lines to remember all that but any time
on myself I'm like I'm chilling I'm
myself a Jewish you owe us for you you
see us you see that chemistry media
tight tight well points to her for not
loving she told me she also went into
heightened mamabear mode with some of
the nervous young contestants backstage
and yet despite the nerves
two of those pint-sized acts really
stole the show
[Music]
ten-year-old Angelica Hale dazzled the
judges with a stunning cover of Zed's
clarity they'll be even got a bit
emotional
the way that you interpreted every
single lyric meant something so powerful
thank you so much me I'm not going to
cry it's like a rule of course survive
be shown it alive and I'm the kind of
person whatever I feel just come down
did you realize that she was going to be
so connected and get so emotional I
never knew but I was so happy when I
found out it's kind of nice to make an
adult cry right yes I had that effect on
people who's anyway another standout
performer 12 year old Darcy Linda
singing ventriloquist her newest puppet
a mouse named Oscar who had a bit of a
crush he's a human and you're a mouse
well I didn't think that would be an
issue
I mean Heidi was married to a seal to
win Mel over all scre saying Mel a
Jackson 5 classic
yeah
[Applause]
it's all amazing to be on that huge
stage do you think you got a shot with
Mel B I learned my partner and I if you
do get the chance to take Mel on a date
what are you doing where you going Oh
George is better on a beach on I love
that that's right I talked to puppets
now my job is weird and I love it
all right let's keep the good vibe going
with some super exciting movie news
after coyly dodging questions about
whether he'd returned as James Bond
Daniel Craig finally put us out of our
misery while visiting The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert last night
Craig we could use some good news here
Daniel Craig will you return as James
Bond yes everybody
I can be happy wonderful yeah we are
excited for that too alright Craig who
is the sixth actor to play double O
seven will suit up as the secret agent
in his fifth consecutive film in the
blockbuster franchise but he also told
Colbert this will be his last but you
know what we will take it alright
meanwhile I thought it would be nice to
share this update on the families of the
victims of the Manchester attack you
guys may recall a bomb went off at
ariana grande's concert in May and left
22 people dead
well now we're learning that the
families of those victims will receive
three hundred and twenty-four thousand
dollars each from the wheel of
Manchester emergency fund that fund was
set up following the attack and raised
over 23 million dollars largely in part
to our ease benefit show that took place
in June in the city I just thought we
could all hear some good news out of
that tragedy
now speaking of keeping things positive
Demi Lovato who is these cities and
fiercest she's ever been has teamed up
with Kate Hudson and fabletics for her
own line of athletic wear and she's
opening up to our Katy Kraus about her
journey to self-acceptance you seen the
happiest that you've ever been both
physically and mentally for anything
that you've learned about yourself the
most in the last year well I take care
of my mental health it's definitely
something that I prioritize as well as
my physical health I see a therapist two
days a week I reached out to people but
whenever I'm struggling with something I
work out I eat clean I have a healthy
support system around me I do everything
that it takes to maintain a happy
healthy lifestyle you've been so open
and candid about your struggles and
about body shame or that something that
you're still dealing with I don't really
deal with body shamers anymore because I
don't look at it and I think the more
attention that you give it the more
power it has over you I focus on just
what I see in the mirror and that's a
beautiful person
and regardless of what I think of my
body that day I know that nobody can
take Who I am away from and if I see a
comment that says that she's fat or
whatever it I let it roll off my back
because I just know that I'm healthy and
I'm doing everything that I can to be
healthy whatever my body is right now is
what it is so love it or hate it I'm
still going to love it if there's
anything to take away from Demi and you
know what this show for that matter it
to be kind of one another and definitely
be kind of yourself I leave you with
that all my friends and we'll have more
entertainment nugget for you tomorrow so
you know the deal
hit subscribe like comment and share and
then dance all right I'll see you
tomorrow bye II